le Parti socialiste cool gentiment on va
dire mais vous vous êtes toujours à la
une de l'actualité régulièrement vous
soigner vos apparitions publiques de
façon très précise
je vous en remercie et vous avez laissé
entendre un Radio-Canada récemment que
Ben vous pourriez être candidate à la
présidentielle de 2022 il y a une
logique il y a une logique je dis pas
que ce sera le cas mais quand on me
posait la question je vais pas dire non
je passe que d'abord le temps où les
femmes toujours s'excuser de vous
demander pardon parce que peut-être
qu'on n'est pas à la hauteur ça suffit
donc je me dis mais si on peut aussi en
poser cette question là un homme bien
oui tiens pourquoi pas et en plus c'est
dans la logique des convictions qui qui
sont les miennes vous savez que dans mon
dernier livre c'est le féministe c'est
l'écologie c'est la
démocratie en tout cas je les porte
depuis longtemps et vous n'avez jamais
été président de la République
contrairement à d'autres c'est ça
peut-être le moment de
des femmes le temps des femmes est
peut-être venu non